I'd been ill for like two or three weeks  and I woke up one morning I was sleeping  in my mum's bed I was age four or five I  woke up and and uh the the pillow was I  was like stuck to the pillow and um it  was like I thought I checked my hands  there was like blood over them and and  then I tried to wake my mum and she was  like go back to sleep it was like 4am  5am so I was like okay I'll go back to  sleep then and then I wake up at like  six or seven looked down it's actually  all red everywhere and um she turned  over looked at me and we didn't have a  phone in the house so it didn't have  like a landline phone and so she had to  go shout like two balconies down to the  street for someone to like call an  ambulance and come free so it was like  literally didn't have anything